俺ん家にはですね,、このノブコがいる部屋
よっ！
とりあえず暖かさの絨毯はひいたんですけど それ以外は何にもなくて
後輩とか友達とかが泊まりに来るときには大抵ここでこういうのを使って
寝てるわけなんですけども
さみしい！　とてもさみしいんですよ
何にもない
そしてもうすぐ
だろ
というわけでちょっとこの寂しい部屋に
こたつを置こうと思いましてこたつを買ってみました。
えっ
あぁあー！
でかいんすよ
amazonの中だと最大級クラスに
大きなこたつでした。
これがあれば…
これがあればクリスマスを乗り切れる！
というわけで、こたつを配置するよ。
いや、ただほんとね、ただ皆
「ただのこたつ作る動画か」
「あー出た出た
ただのこたつ作る動画か。」
あーぁー
「こたつ作る動画か。」と思ってるじゃないですか。
プッ!
全然デカイですよ。多分みんなの想像
絶する大きさになると思うんで早速作っていくよ！
いくぞー
カチャン…
やべっ
これは多分あれだ
こたつに掛けるこたつ布団的なヤツだ
ダーー！
やべ
血が止まんねー
ゴミだー
え、まって本当にめっちゃでかいっすよ、これ多分・・・えっ・・・
うわうわでかでかでか・・・・
こんなサイズですよ？めっちゃでかい・・・
あぁー！
えぇ
めんどくせーな、おい
骨組みみたいなの多分出さないとダメですね
オッケー
これでもう基本パーツは揃ったはずですね
ゴミゴミー
ゴミー
たくみふくしゃちょー：おぉ
はじめしゃちょー：あぁー！
は：うはっはっ
あのですね
昔こたつ買ったことあるんですけど
作るのが実はちょーめんどいんですよね
あぁ！
なんかこういうね
こういうネジとかを使ってちゃんとね留めないとダメなんですよ
めんどくさいんですけど
やるっきゃねぇ！
はい、というわけでようやく完成でございます
ほんとになんかうあぁ
懐かしい
こたつといえばこれですよ
これで温度をちゃんと温かくするってやつなんですけど
まぁなんせ..
なんせもう冬といったらこたつだと思ってるんで
むしろなんか昔こたつ買ったんですけど
なんで今まで
この部屋にこたつ無かったんだろうって思ってて
ようやく
こたつに入りながら寝れるという
もうすべての人類の夢が
叶えられそうです
早速組み立てていきまあすsas..
うわシンプルにもうサイズが凄い
え、やばいよこれだってもう
なんかそこらへんのベットくらいの大きさありますよ、これ
あ、やばい折れちゃう
折れちゃう、え、これ大丈夫？
え、これまって大丈夫？
大丈夫？
これ弱いやつだったらやだな
あぁでも全然、僕が乗っても壊れません
音！
このモフモフ生地がもうたまんない
え、これマジで俺ヤバい
もう...
あ、ヤバ
もう俺だめだこれ
ヤバいヤバい
感染してるわ
誰か
みかん持ってこーーい！
やばい
あっあっあ
あっ
下に敷くやつだ
最後机を乗せて
完成でーーす
はぁ
やばい！！
はい、というわけでこたつ設置したんですけども
見てくださいこの大きさ
１、２、３、４、５、６人ぐらい
入れるんですけど
ポイントは
いつでもお客様をお迎えできる
近未来を漂わせる
色んな要素が詰まった部屋なんですけども
まあ、このこたつに入っちゃえば
誰でも瞬時に
永遠の眠りについてしまう
そんな素晴らしいフィールドが出来てしまいました
まあ最近外が寒くなってきたので
皆さん風邪にはお気を付けください
そして僕はもう、こたつから出たくありません
室内万歳！
エンディング♪